the hard thing about that is that you
could do a thing called line reading
where
they're paying you to get this right
first time yeah so the first time i see
the script is when i go in there
yeah and i'm sure that was that the same
for you with poppy magic beforehand
with pop team epic i got sent not only
the script about
three weeks before i went in but i also
got a cd
with [ __ ] the actual visuals so it's
like amazing so i could practice ahead
of time
and apparently that's normal in the
anime industry that's that's just like
the japanese trust system
it's like we trust that you will not
leak this that just sounds like
a leak waiting to happen because i
didn't any other i didn't sign a
contract either
yeah they just got sent this without an
ending they just sent it to me
hoping that i wouldn't leave this bro i
i
i can maybe count on my hands the amount
of time i received the script before i
got there
like yeah it was like never really yeah
and so i would get the script in front
of me i'd maybe have two minutes to
quickly go over it
but they immediately expected me to like
nail it first time and again there's
words
i've never even seen the english
language they come up in these scripts
right
i don't know what these words are but
i'm expected to like nail it whilst i'm
also reading it for the first time
and that's what they're paying you an
absurd amount of money like i know
[ __ ] people who run like official
discords for like bandai or something
you have to sign mdas
here you are just actually voiceless get
getting it the entire script
is episode nine six months before it
comes out
no it was crazy like i got it in the
mail they didn't even tell me they were
going to send it because i was also
assuming that i was going to see the
script and everything
when i got it that's not how it is yeah
right that's what i heard about dubbing
do that as well yeah yeah
that's what i heard but not only that
but when i when i also cameoed uh
in the uh grisaia phantom trigger
game yeah they also sent me the script
like two weeks beforehand as well
they didn't send me the visuals but they
sent me the script like the physical
script and i had to go in with my
physical script i think the difference
is
normally in the western industries
they're still editing the script like
the day off
yeah like so normally the script that
you get might not even be the final
draft
also people don't trust anyone in this
world which is which is
of course you know this is this is the
country the way you can leave like your
[ __ ] laptop in the middle of a diner
go to the bathroom and then come back
and just trust that nobody's gonna take
it
yeah you know i i just wanted to leak
the boat stuff i don't even care
yeah that it's crazy but i mean you know
did you get paid well for the both thing
though oh yeah i got paid really well oh
yeah but that's like that's like the
voice actors dream is
i didn't i didn't do it for the money i
should because it was fun